Kesha performs for the first time since  dropping her sexual-assault lawsuit  against dr. Luke the 29 year old singer  took the stage in Atlantic City on  Saturday night and thank the audience  for sticking by her side during quote  the hardest years of her life saying I  could not have made it through without  you  due to the lawsuit she could only  perform old material which fans  reportedly loved like her 2010 hit we  are who we are  and I witnessed at the sold-out concert  tells ET you could tell she was happy to  be performing again and the crowd loved  her and it seems like the love was  mutual Kesha took to Twitter following  her performance and gush with excitement  quote the show I have always wanted to  put on I'm so happy  see y'all out there on the road creeps